hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights at candy's -
now this game was released hours ago
just hours ago and oddly enough not too
soon after I finished five nights at
candy's 1 so this is one of the few five
nights at Freddy's foam games that I'm
going to play hey how's it going hi how
are you doing
yes I'm right here I never go anywhere
else I literally have no life
whoa you lost the bet well I've lost
many bets and many unfortunate things
have happened to me what are you
referring to you know what that means
nope not really we could be a little
more informative ya have to spend five
nights in that old factory again again
what kind of bed would I make that that
would be done or else people will think
you're a chicken scaredy ah type up a
reply you bet ass bag I ain't going back
there by the hair by the ha
you bad l'm al what was so funny but no
don't fade to black
oh boy it comes first night everybody so
I wonder what sort of improvements
they've made on the first one because
five nights of Candy's is actually a
very good one with unique animatronics a
different environment you're surrounded
by darkness press space to use the
camera flash from your cell phone use
this to briefly be able to see down the
dark hallway put the mouse towers to
turn on the camera panel this doesn't
seem good I've got the equivalent of a
camera flash oh no that's not good you
know they come with a flash lowboy flick
the mouse to go back up click on the
camera icons to view the cameras you can
call any of the internal found in the
building throw the camera panel any
phone you call will make a ringing noise
which will echo throughout the central
hall the animatronics can only hear the
phones if they are in the same room as
the phone or if they are in the central
hallway yuasa phones to learn en our
tragg Alastair hall
get out what be careful they reach the
room with the ringing further try to
ride disable the phone oh man there's
gonna be a this is gonna be a
and a half alrighty then
you're surrounded okay I guess I need to
turn these off oh I'm on my own have I
been playing how'd I have known oh hi
whoa
hey there how you doing now you get to
be annoyed by oh well that ain't good ah
so about this situation that I don't
like let me count the ways of which I am
boned 1 oh hello
that's number 1 oh I mean oh ah oh no hi
oh hi okay that's fine that's good oh my
god this is terrifying oh no I don't
like this oh no no no no no hi are you
doing get back there Oh oh boy whoa hey
what are you doing there okay that's
what I thought
you better have gone away yeah so you're
there holy crap what is on your oh I see
one of your cheeks dropped oh oh man oh
this is not okay this is a million ways
of not okay how am I supposed to survive
this how am I supposed to survive five
nights or seven nights as it's more
likely gonna be hot tits oh god damn it
that is good system by the way that is a
really good system
there's a terrifying system but that's
actually pretty good
I can't remember what oh man I need to
turn up my volume I can't hear anything
Oh oh boy I mean that's in the door oh
okay oh good god
go please leave you have a call waiting
for you cut them like disable ooh you
are not okay I like this camera better
than the last one how you doing back
there
oh hey Oh how'd you get that so quickly
that's not okay how'd you do that how do
you do that hi I'm just waiting for
another one of you to pop out of nowhere
yes sir good fungi oh my god there's so
no oh man hi
is your friend around here or something
or do I need to worry about that I mean
I need to be worried about a lot of
things both in my life and in the game
but oh god you're so persistent
can you go oh that's not gonna work is
it it's too far away
yes go over here okay
banging lead
[Music]
uh-huh yeah okay I'm just gonna try to
lead her oh no that won't work there's
no real place that doesn't connect to
the hallway oh boy
hello so this works so I can bounce you
around
please go down okay okay you know like
you that all she know like oh man it's
like a direct route no matter what oh
man that is oh that is fantastic and
this is the first night it is the first
what's good of all hey how's going
what's gonna be like when there's six
different animatronics coming at me from
all angles including behind I'm more
concerned about the behind one okay so
if I'm gonna study this there's a vent
live at ready hi
why did it do that I didn't put the
camera down and just did it by itself
why did I agree to this bad why would I
come back if I've experienced this
before it said you're gonna have to
stand the abandoned factory again or
else people are gonna think of a chicken
we could like assbag excuses that
there's a drawing of an animatronic down
on the ground it looked like a bear that
Freddy fazbear weird weird Oh No
no I don't know where oh hi you're there
okay
you disappeared for a little bit okay
5:00 a.m. are I go over here please
so there are vents I do notice that
there are vents that connect the
different places around here but I don't
know if they can actually be used yet
I'm gonna find that out probably in the
next night if I can roll straight
through this one I'm gonna piledrive in
the night too and then see how far I can
go do which I have a feeling the death
is better than lurking around a lot of
corners at least I don't have to listen
to a phone call work okay everything is
fine
everything is good Oh everything's not
good going yes he down at the bottom
there that it looks like a drawing of a
lion or a cat it might be it might be a
cat okay that might be a cat almost done
just gonna be longer you know I do
ponder why there's a system of phone
setup like this logically speaking it's
not a hundred four feet Oh God
well it's too much why did you do that
why not just let me enjoy my celebration
with happy children cheering for me Oh
what is that
oh no it's the first game hello
is there a Radhika's in there Oh
probably well let's go let's go Jojo why
is version 2.x doubt on that one
well that doesn't seem very happy or fun
the other ones version - the other one
seemed fine but what happen - version 1
is version 1 the maniacal version that's
gonna kill everybody because that seems
more accurate at this point ok so if I
remember my layout this is gonna go to
the side and then the office is going to
be down here
ooh boy hello oh hey that looked like a
puppet I'm not 100% sure on that one but
I was pretty much a puppet we're in 1989
the year I was born
should I be concerned about all this
thing's definitely yes there's a
trombone player that's having some
problems that's really bizarre oh hey
I'm blank
hi blankie blue okay goodbye Oh what I'm
supposed to I got a key I just got to
figure out where the heck the key goes
oh of course the locked door in the
beginning work where radhika's was
whatever his name wasn't I even remember
okay so I got the key so it should be
fun
hi okay hurry then bills good key okay
cool
rolling right along night too let's see
what you got in store for me I'm gonna
die which is probably more likely than
the alternative for me surviving and
actually being good at a game but
instead I'm gonna persevere okay what do
we got in store for us today one of the
animun one of the animatronics will
attempt to climb into the ventilation
systems to get you if you hear noises
coming from the vents find the camera
the animatronic is on and then call the
phone in the room to scare it away from
the vent what what a load of ass hi how
you doing where where I don't know where
that is
oh oh I know is it is oh hi oh god aah
aah no no it was
[Music]
okay I didn't know what that was I
thought who's dead like a hundred ways I
thought I who's dead oh my goodness hi
what are you doing all the way over
there
so when one phone is ringing I can't do
anything until that phone is done so she
should just roll yes she should just
rush me through so if I hit it from all
the way on the opposite end then that
should just lead her from one end to the
other or if it should act as a deterrent
if she ever goes too you know oh hi oh
hi I can't yeah hi huh okay that was a
blur okay I didn't see that monkey
before what the hell was Jojo doing oh
[Applause]
hi how are you
missing girl 17-year old Marilyn Schmidt
did not show up for school yesterday
after she allegedly been staying
overnight with her friend in this week
Marilyn's friend Radel later revealed
that Marilyn was spending the night in
an abandoned Factory on st. Antonious
Road and that they had lied Marilyn's
parents Marilyn had lost a bet with some
of her classmates where she had to spend
five nights in a factory apparently
again because she'd done it before I
don't know why okay so that's how I'm
gonna play for this episode I'm gonna
get to this game very again soon I have
no idea how this is going to be when
there's more animatronics put in the mix
because okay this is going to be very
interesting so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know if you
want me to play this game to completion
I probably will but I'd like your input
on it it seems like a very good and
unique one with new mechanics which is
all I really ask for out of a five guys
for these games so thank you again and
as always I will see you
in the next video investigation came out
on those bloody Robo fees
[Music]